und zwar möchte ich beginnen mit dem
thema masken mund nasenschutz das ist
ein thema dass doch viele in der
bevölkerung interessiert und ich möchte
noch mal die position des robert koch
instituts deutlich machen
wir müssen unterscheiden es gibt einen
sogenannten medizinischen mund
nasenschutz das sind auch die
sogenannten op masken und es gibt
sogenannte ffp masken diese masken
müssen für das medizinische personal
vorbehalten bleiben für die bevölkerung
gilt folgendes um sich selbst und andere
vor ansteckung zu schützen bleibt und
wird auch so bleiben das wichtigste
abstand zu halten
eine infektion die über topfen
tröpfcheninfektion übertragen wird vor
der schützt man sich am besten indem man
von einem abstand kennen uns von
mindestens anderthalb meter die gute
händehygiene die wir ebenfalls von
beginn an propagieren und die husten und
niesen regeln beachten
das bleibt bestehen das bleibt wichtig
und das sollten sie immer beherrschen
stoffmasken auch behelfs massen oder
textil massen genannt könnten dabei
helfen tröpfchen beim husten oder
sprechen zurückzuhalten
sie könnten dabei helfen andere zu
schützen
aber sie helfen nicht dabei den
maskenträger selbst zu schützen
das ist wirklich sehr wichtig zu
verstehen es gibt für diesen fremdschutz
bislang keine wissenschaftlichen belege
das sage ich deutlich aber es erscheint
plausibel dass man einen fremdschutz
ausüben kann
neuere studien zeigen dass ein teil der
kogit 19 infizierten so leichte symptome
hat dass sie diese symptome kaum
bemerken oder dass sie gar keine
symptome haben und den erreger trotz dem
ausscheiden an orten an denen man den
abstand nicht immer einhalten kann zum
beispiel in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
oder im supermarkt da könnte das tragen
einer maske in solchen fällen vermutlich
das risiko reduzieren
andere anzustecken das ist unsere
einschätzung aber ich möchte das noch
mal betonen man selber wird nicht vor
der übertragen geschützt mit einer
solchen maske wer krank ist und symptome
hat der sollte unbedingt zu hause
bleiben und bei bedarf ärztliche hilfe
in anspruch nehmen wenn sie krank sind
bitte gehen sie dann nicht einkaufen
bitte fahren sie nicht wollen auch nicht
mit einer textil maske sondern wenn sie
krank sind bleiben sie bitte zu hause
und für alle anderen gilt damit diese
stoff textil oder behelfs masken oder
wie immer wieder nennen funktionieren
ist ganz wichtig dass diese maske
richtig sitzt also eng anliegt sie
mussten nach durchfeuchtung gewechselt
werden
und wichtig ist beim tragen der maske
dürfen sie sich nicht ständig anfassen
oder zurecht zupfen
denn dann fassen sie sich ins gesicht
und genau das soll man nicht das heißt
also diese masken dürfen keinen falschen
schutz vor täuschen sondern sie müssen
sie gut behandeln und gut damit umgehen
denn das schlimmste was passieren könnte
wenn das tragen der maske dazu führt
dass man sich in einer falschen
sicherheit wiegt man muss auch mit einer
solchen textil maske oder behelf maske
stoffmaske wie immer wie sie nennen
abstand halten sich an die husten und
niesen halten und die händehygiene
beachten sonst schadet das tragen einer
solchen maske mehr als dass es nützt das
ist die einschätzung die wir im moment
dazu geben
auch wir müssen die situation immer
wieder neu bewerten die lage ist sehr
dynamisch und generell so dass für
option immer wieder prüfen und anpassen
werden so wie wir das seit beginn dieser
epidemie tun eine tägliche
lage-einschätzung das ist unser job